[Music]
well here we are at the finale of the
final season watching the opening
credits for the final time sending the
opening credits of this show has become
so comforting to me i know i can always
find a floss somewhere in the full two
minutes of prelude because that's just
how life is right if you want to find
something wrong you can always find it
and justify it to yourself and even
point it out to others so thank you game
of thrones for having credit so long
that there's always some [ __ ] to make up
and giving us this weekly moment
together episode opens up on one minute
and 51 seconds of tyrion john and davos
walking also tyrion isn't wearing a mask
to avoid breathing in the charred
remains of men women and children in
this scene it's a little hard to buy how
much danny's actions affected tyrion and
jon when they can't even bother to help
this guy passing them at least give him
aloe or something when aloe help just
stop and assist the man before his skin
falls off there are skeletons in the
foreground of this building that was
directly on drogon's dragonfire path
meaning the dragonfire was so hot it
entered a building and melted the muscle
in connective tissue leaving the bones
behind this makes me wonder how the
corpses in the streets still had their
tissue intact considering those people
had no cover at all
john survives this the writers were like
the foundation of the map room cracks
open symbolically showing a divide and
the props department was like bricks
everywhere if you think you've added too
many or that they're on top of something
of storytelling importance well you are
wrong more bricks when you wonder how
this episode managed to be movie length
just remember they chose to show tyrion
picking up a torch rather than just get
to him walking down the stairs with a
torch we can put two and two together
and figure out he found a light source
so tyrion confirms the end of his
family's lineage and uses his super
instincts to dig through a rubbled keep
and get directly to his sibs then he
turns around and gets back in time to
hear danny's speech which convinces him
she's turning mad
did i what the [ __ ] that right maybe i
should have paid attention in castle
masonry class at fantasy world building
school but where did all the rubble come
from the floor above a buckled wall
right now just appears that there's
random self-standing piles of brick that
aren't from an important load-bearing
archway or something pan up and show me
the hole in the floor to justify how
they're laying on top of a massive pile
of bricks or cover my tuition and send
me back to school you know honestly they
look really good for being crushed by
the weight of all the bricks in this
castle
that's not how cpr works and now because
we have time we will watch john take
every single step along this path to the
queen do you like feet well boy are you
gonna love all the walking we have in
store for you today
how did worm get up here so fast he was
slitting throats a few minutes ago and
jon went directly to find danny unless
even the fictional characters aren't
feeling a sense of timing and decided to
take a tea break rather than show us how
this all ends
oh
sh
all hail one of the best shots of queen
danny in the series
but also i blame this shot for the spike
in angel wing murals popping up for
photo ops in all major cities dear sin
diary today i spent 30 minutes watching
braiding tutorials on youtube in order
to confidently say that rapunzel
targaryen has approximately 50 yards of
hair on her head and her posture will be
horrible if she isn't highly focused on
keeping the weight distributed properly
i find it all too convenient that
danny's army remnants fit perfectly in
this courtyard i bet drogon munched
extra people just to be sure it had a
cinematic aesthetic
i like to think the dothraki stop and
look at danny and all because i can't
believe her voice can carry all this way
so clearly
did danny and drogon rehearse this
speech together because it's either that
or drogon has really awesome dramatic
dragon timing what are you doing here he
sure did say how the [ __ ] did you get up
the massive set of stairs past an army
without being noticed strangely and i
know a killer when i see one and because
arya says so we're supposed to follow
suit and turn our dany adoration to
disgust without actually seeing much
more than a wink at her madness i think
so i mean not i i don't trust anything
happening right now our queen doesn't
keep prisoners for long which makes me
ask the question why is tyrion still
alive they were lining up soldiers on
the street and slicing their necks like
it was a normal deli slice tuesday why
does tyrion get to live any longer dany
even warned him the last time she would
kill him if he betrayed her again
my father was an evil man
my sister was an evil woman
pile up all the bodies of all the people
they ever killed
there still won't be half as many as our
beautiful queen slaughtered in a single
day ah the old game of my father and
sister might have murdered a lot of
people but they aren't as murdery as
your girlfriend slash aunt i know it all
too well wait everywhere she goes
evil men die
and we cheer her for it well that's your
fault show for making her so damn
amazing i wonder why jon is allowed to
talk freely to tyrion without someone
else keeping an eye on them jon tried to
stop greyworm from killing prisoners of
war and dany knows jon is the one true
king certainly someone is suspicious
enough to eavesdrop as tyrion hard hints
at a danny assassination this scene just
made me think of a joke what's john's
middle name it's walking in the get it
john walking in the snow because it's
and
hey don't blame me blame the finale for
being so boring i'm trying to fill the
emptiness with something entertaining as
amazing as this looks i refuse to
believe a [ __ ] dragon would be cold
enough to accumulate layers of snow
can't verify this by research because
this is a fantasy world but this fantasy
world is about to show the same dragon
melt the [ __ ] out of an iron throne so
you know drogon runs warm danny gets to
see the throne for the first time and
realize what she's accomplished blah
blah blah but what i can't figure out is
why there are no guards with danny she's
been walking all over the city with
guards in tow makes no sense why they
wouldn't be up here with her now there
could be some straddlers hiding up here
ready to strike not to mention because
there are conveniently no guards jon is
able to kill her with ease
you are my queen
no
and always which will only be a few more
seconds but john is an [ __ ] and
doesn't clarify that inserting to the
hilt without explicit consent
the
end
overkill looking away from a dragon
that's still considering its calorie
intake for the day and determining your
snack potential we find out shortly that
jon was arrested for murdering danny
shortly after this but how were they
able to even prove it drogon took her
away so unless jon was dumb enough to
confess he could have easily said she
wrote off on drogon and he had no clue
where she was going but john probably is
dumb and love enough to confess
the next 30 seconds are dedicated to
tyrion's thoughtful expression rather
than giving us 30 seconds of dany
revealing a few more surefire reasons
she was beyond redeemable say another
word about killing my brother and i'll
cut your throat threatening to murder
someone in front of so many witnesses
fiara comes back one day with a slit
throat are you better hope she's got a
rock solid alibi
there is land in the reach goodland the
people that used to live there are gone
make it your own start your own house
with the unsullied as your bannermen
grey worm and the unsullied have all
been castrated there's no way for them
to procreate and start a house and have
any kind of family legacy this isn't the
great offer that davos thinks it is
everyone has heard enough words from you
you're right and yet the finale will
continue to give us maximum tyrion talks
if the end story is about the stark
children then why not let them have
their speeches in screen time and if
this story isn't about ned's bloodline
changing the future of westeros then
what are we even doing here you're the
most powerful people in westeros choose
one this works
please
embarrassing uncles he crossed beyond
the wall
a crippled boy
and became the three-eyed raven whatever
that means
there's still a night's watch the world
will always need a home for bastards and
broken men you mean exiles and people
deem to be a threat to bloodlines yeah
great wheel breaking their show you
shall take no wife hold no lands
father no children and all this will be
policed by precisely no one no one is
very happy except tyrion i would assume
considering he gets to walk free while
jon has to serve a life sentence at the
night's watch was it right well i did it
doesn't feel right questions the writers
had for george rr martin somehow make it
into the episode ask me again in 10
years are they foreshadowing the release
of another game of thrones series in 10
years
they are
aren't they
no
audience at home don't turn that dial
from the show that delivered riveting
dialogue that's propelled you from slump
to slump throughout this episode they
bring you to brienne
reading a [ __ ] book okay but why turn
the page to continue writing when
there's so much more room down here
jaime's entry here in the book of
brothers reads he took riverrun from the
tully rebels without loss of life the
corpse of brendan blackfish tully might
have something to say about that for
getting the dot on the lowercase j of
all the shows to forget the tittles
she spelled sister wrong wait no love
her she spelled lover wrong wait no
mother is
there is zero chance that inc had dried
yet so all the writing brienne just
completed is now a spudge what's this
a song of ice and fire roll appendixes
and drogon
any word no that's still a terribly
unoriginal name for a dragon oh you were
asking if anyone had spotted him i see
but i still stand by what i said about
the name thing the master of coin looks
forward to helping the master of ships
speaking in the third title i once
brought a jackass and a honeycomb into a
brothel are tyrion's final words in this
series
careful john remember you can't take a
wife
the
end
the cinematic angles cut thematically
between the siblings except for bran
bran who could be [ __ ] warging right
now by the way his siblings walk but
bran rolls and flies and why are we
seeing any of that
the
and
no
not really the end though
where is bran riding drogon like falcore
style through the air with this pissed
race come on thrones come on
shame shame
shame
so
how was burning man my name is
you killed my father
prepared to die it's over
these men are prisoners this isn't over
until i say it's over
sorry okay relax dude
yeah i can fly i don't know what to say
really
three minutes till the biggest battle of
our professional lives did you bring any
wine
no i am not drinking any [ __ ] merlot
you
shall not
pass
doctor doctor
doctor doctor doctor
doctor
stop looking at me
swan party
[Music]